[musique]
N'importe quel jour le matin, il est tôt et je sors à neuf heures
Neuf heures et demie et il n'y a pas de place, donc nous restons
Les gens d'Alizon, qu'est-ce qu'on est censé faire avec ça ?
Un travail désordonné, à vrai dire, signifie du travail
Pas organisé ou ayant un problème d’organisation. Il y a un problème
En réglant un problème, nous savons quel est le problème
C'est exactement ta journée
Nouveau gars
Il y a des gens qui n'ont pas de médiateur et d'autres qui ne peuvent pas le faire.
Ils entrent
[musique]
La première chose
Beaucoup d'entre eux, je les ai tous vus par erreur
[musique]
Khartoum, je le jure, quel endroit
Mais personne ne nous a refusé nos droits, mais il n'y a pas de traitement
Pas de boisson, pas d'éducation, rien
[musique]